I do think there's a deep moral
responsibility that you know as the Good
Book says am I my brother's keeper I
think to some extent there is that of
course the development developed world
can only do so much at the end of the
day developing countries have to take
their own responsibilities there are
political leaders they have to be the
ones that set the standards that
implement the policies and I think what
has happened over recent years
particularly since the millennium
development goals have been agreed
there's been a greater sense of
interdependence of responsibility the
primary responsibility and the primary
ownership for development has to rest
with the countries themselves with the
politicians and the people of those
countries of those countries but then
many we do need to help those countries
in structured and sustained way in order
to you know in order to achieve
development